good morning believe nation it seven I
started to believe life series to try to
round out our knowledge gaps as
entrepreneurs not only focus on business
stuff but give us some useful tools to
help us in our daily lives and so this
weekend we're going to focus on cooking
tips for beginners something that I
probably need to pay a lot of attention
to hope you enjoy
[Music]
cooking is a life skill for me it's
fundamentally important is just as
crucial as keeping fits because Latin
history geography no disrespect but if
you're not going to teach that for the
rest your life it doesn't come into play
cooking does three times a day seven
days a week for the rest of your life is
to eat so we don't cook three meals a
day but there's one meal cross that day
that needs to be absolutely you your
honor plates done properly healthfully
chokes and sets you up because you are
what you eat so we should never
underestimate the importance of food
because that's the fuel
okay loving people knife skills really
really important life is short you
normally eat three times a day you
probably cook a lot of meals in your
life and sit there clanking around
taking lumps in your body off and like
just being slow and rubbish not good so
let's get you good at it so there's four
things in front of me right now a small
paring knife nice little darling here
great for two little preparations
nipping things splicing herbs a really
good all-around knife right everyone
needs one and essential okay now not not
so really all around nice but this is a
carving knife you can use it for carving
mints and stuff it does leave a little
bit of a line but it doesn't really
bother me but most important you've got
the teeth in it the serrated sort of
jagged dagger edges it it's a really
good all-around carving knife there and
then the knife that you're going to use
90% of the time right an eight to ten
inch chef's knife absolutely brilliant
well-balanced nice grip
you've got that thick kind of base here
and that base is also thick here so with
little chicken legs you can just Nick
them off you know and just literally
break bones and bits and pieces like
that you've got that nice thick edge
here so that's what you need we've got
the sharpener here every time you use a
knife bottom to tip bottom to tip just
do it once on each side okay there's
three methods of chopping that I suggest
you learn okay and that'll get you at a
ninety nine percent of stuff this first
method I'm going to teach you the cross
chop is brilliant because hands and
fingers are like this there's no way on
the knife and that is very very easy
right it's States as fingers no limbs no
body part anywhere near this knife and
then when you're chopping things use it
almost like a dustpan and brush this for
instance I cut this onion this just
cross chop so it's bad it's hacking it
right but then you keep going through it
and then you're kind of it's almost like
a food Pro
it's going to get fine eventually right
but it's falling off so then you sweep
it up and you put it in the middle this
is quite a slow way of doing this but it
is efficient and it is safe it might you
might see people doing that never ever
ever ever do that
always fingers like that I've seen
people take their fingertips off if they
do that okay don't do it and like that
so let's just get rid of that so I'm
going to go straight in to tap chopping
the idea is that I put my thumb here and
I put my fingers here and my fingers are
tucked in and I pull my fingers as I'm
cutting all the way down and then I redo
it and all the way down okay if you
forget your thumb and it comes out
you're going to cut that off as well and
I have we all have but I didn't have
anyone telling me how to do it so at the
top of the knife is feeling that that
finger but not obviously it knows where
it is
I'm not bringing it up beyond here you
never ever bring this blade beyond the
point where your finger goes in okay so
never hire them they're right slowly as
I'm slicing now you're going to go slow
to start with and then you can start to
pick up the speed to the point where it
doesn't master anymore okay and the
reality is right now and where my
fingers are because I know what's
happening until this point at this point
I've got wobble again seeks I'm getting
towards the end of the courgette what
are you doing when you got wobble on a
flat surface wobbling no right then you
can stop again until then and your well
being again then you go flat surface
right
so shopping is all about non wobbly
[ __ ] right you're in control of that so
let's just have a little girl on this
chili that's a rock chopping chilli
perfect for rock chopping let's change
the angle let's show you it like this if
you look at this chilli now it doesn't
matter on going slow or fast notice
fingered in thumb pulling the fingers
towards it that little edge of my finger
controlling where the blade pure and at
no point did that blade ever go near a
finger is vulnerable now so then we're
much much more careful and then we
finish that the chilli
practice makes perfect if your fingers
are always out the way you can't chop it
off it's a really good crowd it's like
learning to write it's like learning to
talk is by learning to ride a bike
it makes your cooking so much quicker
and for the shows out there you can
start it out good luck big lists what
ingredients we'll need for this recipe
make a coherent and comprehensive list
meson plus means organize your spots
that it's laid out by all your
ingredients the most advanced
preparation you could have under the
circumstances before your guests arrive
you know you know what your guests like
sitting there drinking all your liquor
and getting ugly drunk while you're
around in the kitchen we're measuring
sticky ingredients like honey spray a
glass measuring cup with a nonstick
cooking spray like pan to prevent
sticking and allow for an easy cleanup
then fill and when you pour it out
you'll see that it doesn't stick to the
sides of the measuring cup when
measuring liquids use a spouted glass
measuring cup fill with the liquid on
flat surface and then bend down to read
at eye level when measuring dry
ingredients be sure to use a dry
measuring cup if the measuring cup into
a canister this one has granulated sugar
and sweep away the excess with straight
sided utensil when using a scale to
measure items like tomatoes place a bowl
on the scale and press the zero or tare
button which will set the scale to zero
then add the ingredients you're weighing
and you'll see you have an accurate
measure how I love you people have you
ever got a little piece of eggshell in
your eggs when you're cracking them well
let me show you the quickest and easiest
way to get rid of it we've all done it
we're making
we're making a cake and we're cracking
our eggs and then a little bit of random
shell just accidentally Oh falls in to
the egg now the thing is the natural
instinct is to get in there with your
fingers but if you try and get it it
always runs away and it's kind of
annoying the easiest way to do it
believe it or not is to go back to our
friend mr. shell and you can mop it up
can easily get those annoying bits of
shell every single time happy days
let me show you how to remove the skin
easily and fast from an avocado get a
regular spoon like this go in here push
the spoon right on to the skin and push
it against the cup of your hand and
simply knock it out well it's every
single time really really good let me
show you some really easy ways to chop
and slice your garlic we can slice it we
want to get our thumb out of the way we
want our fingers to go over the garlic
like this and just do that little tap
chopping method we can just continue to
chop through this to make the chopped
garlic that's the cross chopping method
very safe just grab your garlic clove
like this just put it on a flat edge
just go about a millimeter slices not
quite to the end like that
then flip it over and do exactly the
same and then you can put it on the side
and then you can literally just slice as
rock chopping method let me show you how
to take the stone out of an avocado
safely so just remove the little bit of
stem from the end it might look like
nothing but that can send your knife in
a totally different direction which is
really dangerous and then quickly
avocado down very importantly and then
carefully but slowly cut using no weight
or power down to the stone in the middle
then slowly rotate the avocado so it
just gently cuts around twist it and
then tap it on the board and off it
comes it's so important to have a sharp
knife let me show you how to sharpen it
first up you need to get a steel start
with a heel of the knife a slight angle
and we go evenly to the tip
and we do the other side so one two
really that all you should need to do
and that's called knife maintenance let
me show you two ways to peel your ginger
in the most efficient way the most
efficient way to peel a piece of ginger
is simply to use a little spoon and
scrape it just like that it barely peels
just the brown skin off let me show you
another way to peel ginger you can make
the most fantastic ginger tea leaves
with a little teaspoon of honey one of
the most important things to do when
you're cooking in the kitchen is secure
your chopping board let me show you how
it's the simplest thing on the planet to
do but just get yourself a little tea
towel place it down like that pour some
water on like this and it will kind of
shape to whatever shape the surface and
the board is I'm going to show you how
to cut and prepare a mango put it to its
flat side like this I put my knife in
and you're going to hit the oval shape
it feather out the knife so it goes
around the pit take this lobe into three
now once you've done that you've got two
choices you can either put the tip of
your knife just under the skin and then
just gently throw the knife over the
skin and just remove that skin like that
or get yourself a sturdy glass nothing
too fragile literally push it it takes
off the flesh like this keep you in one
place you are left with the flesh here
take the end off keep your knife almost
in the same place and then just drill
and roll the pit and that is for the
chef's let me show you the easiest way
to take an egg yolk away from the egg
white now one way is to bounce the yolk
backwards and forwards from one shell to
the other that's the classic but the
thing is sometimes you kind of pierce
the yolk and then it goes in your egg
whites that means your meringue they're
not going to work and that means you've
lost your yolks the other way to do it
crack it into your hand and let it slide
through until you've got your yolk and
then there's one more flamboyant way to
do it get yourself a clean empty bottle
take the top off
squeeze a little bit of the air out and
suck up the yolk I'm going to show you
how you can get those beautiful capsules
out of the pomegranate buy yourself a
beautiful pomegranate cut it open put
your fingers open like that hold the
half over a bowl or a salad or any dish
and just give it a good spanking which
most people love and they literally just
tumble out when you're getting corn off
the cob put a small bowl upside down in
a large bowl take a good sharp knife and
just spin the corn and the corn collects
in the larger bowl it's very clever this
is a cooling rack so like when you're
baking your holiday cookies and all that
but I use it to make a big batch of
guacamole check it out your chard or
fresh avocado squish
[Music]
hey guys the next time you have to slice
a lot of cherry tomatoes so cool one by
one with a paring knife take out some
jelly would fill the bottom lid with a
lot of cherry tomatoes put an extra lid
up on top make one cut and place all
those tomatoes at one time works for
great feeding note and I will mix the
dry ice cream in there awesome I'm
making cupcakes or muffins identical
portions for everybody you don't end up
in the end with some of them bubbling
over gone too short it's off I'm
stealing that idea for sure it's a good
one look how perfectly that goes in and
then de a also it's really fun and easy
and then it comes out exactly even all
the time amazing suggestion if you don't
have one of these little juicers at home
a great tip is to just squeeze the lemon
cut side hop the feet stay with the
lemon and don't fall down into whatever
you're cooking or or prepared when it
comes to freezing food remember black is
back just take a durable freezer bag for
stability if you're dealing with liquid
place it in a bowl or a large measuring
cup like this then fill your hot soup or
stew or sauce in there let it cool
completely and store it nice and flat
once it's frozen you could stack these
up like 10 12 hi guys when you bring
home beautiful fresh basil from the
grocery store do not head for your
fridge basil hate the cold doesn't like
water much either you need to treat it
like fresh-cut flowers trim the bottom
put it in clean water change that water
every couple of days leave it on the
counter not in the fridge and then cover
it with a plastic food-storage bag this
creates a little greenhouse and the
basil will not only not go bad it will
continue to grow you'll use every last
leaf how musical expectations of
yourself when professionals learn how to
make like a holiday slaw they screw it
out your first pot and that's probably
the second and the third so cut yourself
some slack to understand that
and repetition that's efficient some
dishes take repeated doing til you get
them right if you you know you bring it
over you know your new girlfriend's
family for the first time you want to
make a good impression
maybe this is not the day to do
something you've never done before
because something you're very familiar
with you know you do well you're
comfortable with and if you're trying to
do something completely you you know
invite only people over who seem naked
already and that is I think this is one
of this this awful American syndrome of
fear of failure and if you're going to
have a sense of fear of failure you're
just never going to learn how to cook
because cooking is a lot of it it's one
failure after another and that's how you
finally learn princess you got to have
developed what the French call Jamal
booties in law I don't care what happens
I can fall and omelettes can go over all
over the stove I'm going to learn I
shall overcome it's sort of woman's
liberation and I mean everything like
that if you're not going to be ready to
sail you're not going to learn how to
cook that's what that little lecture is
all about but nobody for one thing
nobody knows exactly what you intend so
you can serve them one of your failures
and they maybe think that's what you
intended because thing about cooking
when you're starting actually anyone out
there that's just starting how to cook
I'm actually jealous of you because if I
could go back in time and start learning
how to cook now I'd be a lot more
mindful I wouldn't develop that habit
and one of the biggest habits that cooks
do is they rush and the end up cutting
themselves if you look at the potato and
you're like oh this is kind of wobbly no
there's a chance that your nights going
to slip so when you're cutting make sure
it's firm just go one by one if you're
watching yourself and you're paying
attention just like learning anything
you're not going to develop those bad
habits of rushing and I know cooking
some people like oh I don't have time to
do it it takes too long it's too hard so
a bunch of bullcrap all you have to do
is just have some patience and just
practice when you're cooking not
everything has to be cut the same way
you're a chef if you're going to
culinary school that's your thing and
like you have to cut everything
perfectly as fine
you know in a lot of restaurants they're
very demanding of that but you know if
you're just having fun and you're
cooking for friends things don't have to
be that consistent maybe you know invite
some friends over have a good time cook
for some people or just cook for
yourself as well as you're having fun
with it don't feel like it has to be
intimidating you know the first times
you cook for people try the recipe
yourself a couple times and just see how
it turns out you know and if it's not
good if your friends do you know like
it's not that great or maybe it just
needs more seasoning don't feel like you
have to end like if I taste this right
now I'm like you know it just doesn't
have that boom I'm sitting at the table
I don't just accept defeat I go to the
cabinet I grab the salt I squeeze some
salt in there and mix it around and I'll
be damned if I taste it again to make
sure that's better
there you go it's actually a big
difference if it's still not good we're
going to add some more salt or whatever
you want a lot of times what I'll do is
I'll buy a bunch of stuff just start
heating things up I'll cut these
mushrooms are sauteed it together up
with in a bowl cook the steak and then
once I'm done I'll look and see what I
have is like I'll you know I can make a
little move so sometimes before I'm
really ready to like commit to a certain
kind of dish I just start cooking get
the oven on and get the pans hot just
start cooking away and then the magic
will start to come and the great things
about this kind of food is everything's
going to taste good you throw it on a
tortilla you heat up a tortilla add a
little bit of salsa or something and
next thing you know you're eating
delicious tacos
all right so peppers are there any way
I'm doing this like these fancy sort of
flip things you don't have to do that
but if you want to do it just know that
it's all in the confidence so I'm going
like this I'm kind of getting ready for
it and you sort of see I even lost one
button some big do you fill in the force
delicious
so basically pushing forward and as I'm
pushing at the right moment I just kind
of pull back and it's a finesse thing
you feel it you practice it before you
know it you'll be
pressing your friends a little like wow
he can do the thing that's the thing and
you're cooking the first step to being
impressive and cool being able to do
that thing that stuffy
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know what did you think what did
you learn from this you're going to
apply somehow to your life I'm really
curious other extra tips that you want
to add to the list as well but maybe we
missed that leave it down in the
comments below I'm really curious to see
what you have to say thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you
I'm continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love see
you soon
start clean start with an empty
dishwasher and empty sink and clean
countertop cooking will create dirty
dishes and stuff you use spoons and
spatulas and pots and pans and plates
and scoops and potato writers so if you
have a few areas to put these items
instead of piling items on top of other
items you're in good use a garbage Bowl
save trip to the garbage can by keeping
a garbage bowl close to your working
area prepare your ingredients ahead of
time building your recipe requires
adding certain ingredients in at the
exact right time and of course doing
this reduces a mess created from that
frantic scramble to measure the right
amount of paprika or something get
little bowls or a couple of plates and
do it that way these can be easily
washed when everything is cooking avoid
cross-contamination ensure you have
separate cutting boards and utensils for
meat and vegetables clean cloths keep
those handy for both wiping your hands
and cleaning up spills and of course
paper towels that way you can use them
for cleaning up meat juices
sometimes I even pre-portion paper towel
so that I don't have to touch the roll
with chicken fingers clean spills
immediately I know it seems obvious but
if you spill something on the floor the
stovetop the counter or the backsplash
wipe it up right been in there because
that means less scrubbing for later use
a utensil soap this makes it so you
don't have to even use the dishwasher
for most of the utensils and colory that
is used while cooking just fill a sink
or a bowl with hot water and a couple of
pumps of dish soap when you've got some
down time say well onions are sauteing
you can give these a quick rinse and dry
this is a great thing to do also if
you're hosting a party and you need to
reuse the salad fork for dessert sports
splatter screen these things make a huge
difference in oil splatters around your
stovetop and your backsplash and even
your air vent filters wash items as you
go when you use a knife you wash the
knife when you use a measuring cup you
wash the measuring cup to save water I
just spray just soap and water on the
AIDA
scrub it with a sponge and then rinse it
and let it dry it reduces the strain and
the load size for the dishwasher and it
makes cleaning up after cooking so much
easier since you're just putting items
away as you go instead of having to put
them in the dishwasher and deal with
them later clean while you wait if
you're waiting for pasta to cook or
sauce to reduce you've got a few minutes
this is your golden opportunity to wipe
up counters place items in the
dishwasher or dry anything that's been
hand washed those items while you eat
while you sit down to enjoy your
creation you should have a relatively
clean kitchen that being said remove any
food that you've made from the cooking
vessel before eating and pre soak those
cooking vessels while you eat that way
you've got a head start on arguably the
hardest stuff to clean